biden is favored
to win the election okay as of today
to win the election by the way if you
guys can comment below who do you
think's
winning okay who do you think is winning
can you comment below and say who you
think
is winning the election comment below
between the two
uh if you go a little lower i think the
one thing that was pretty interesting i
said this one says what biden is favor
to win the election
we simulate the election 40 000 times to
see who wins it most often the sample of
outcomes below gives you a good idea of
the range of scenarios of models
uh think it's possible 24 and 100 models
trump wins 76 in 100
biden wins every outcome in our
simulation if you can go up a little bit
all possible elector electro comes
around candidates with higher bars
showing
outcomes that appeared more than in 40
000 simulations
trump wins okay uh biden wins go to the
next one there's a few this is the one
this is the main one to be thinking
about
what states are no matter what voting
trump
and what states are no matter what
voting by them go a little higher go a
little higher so we can see all of them
so
far far right is what nebraska third
district yes is that the far right then
no matter what it's red
bottom it's dc look at it go go on the
nebraska one
nebraska 72 and a half percent are going
to vote for trump
25 for biden go on the far left one dc
look at this one
dc is only 5.7 trump
91 forecasted to vote for
biden okay then you go into the middle
states by the way even texas is barely
in there go to texas they don't have
texas as red texas is 51 4 biden 47
6. you go to middle blue so ohio
ohio they're having who go to ohio ohio
is going to be
this one matters they're putting trump
with ohio north carolina
go to florida close yeah i know go to
the next one
florida you think biden's going to take
florida
i think we'll find out in february well
you think that long
what do you think's going to be 60 days
probably go go to the next one nebraska
is it second district what's that one
right there
nebraska second district biden go to
arizona everybody thinks arizona is a
red state
huh could keep going we're probably
getting
80 percent trump 20 percent back see
with all the people moving to arizona
from california yeah
it's going to be blue go a little lower
to say what states are going to
determine the whole thing go lower
lower go lower no no kyle go lower like
go lower
meaning go lower on the side yeah keep
going keep going keep going
keep going keep going what does it say
here trump popular vote 13 and once
100 biden wins the popular world 87
trump wins are more than 50
go even lower to the last one to talk
about the states here you go
carolina ohio florida iowa arizona
georgia texas pennsylvania wisconsin
these are the states with the closest
races okay
go to that one tipping point
pennsylvania florida wisconsin north
carolina arizona michigan
nevada minnesota colorado it's going to
be interesting it's going to be
interesting what happens over there
i know the debate's happening one next
week by the way we're watching the
debate
live uh we're going to be watching the
debate live here i think it's on the
29th
is it 29th evening we'll be watching a
debate and
uh commenting on it you know one thing
with florida you know really really
close
and michael bloomberg just put 100
million into florida we talked about
that the other day and you wonder how
much of a difference that can make a
hundred million dollars is a lot of tv
commercials you bombard people with that
type of negativity
you know for 40 straight days you wonder
if something like that can make a
difference
right because people do watch tv they
are susceptible to those types of
messages
i tell you i'm sticking to the same
thing if 900 million dollars of
bloomberg's money
only got him 58 delegates a hundred
million dollars spent in florida
is not going to get bite nothing if you
are not an exciting candidate that's
going to win people over you don't
have for a hundred million dollars all
you have to do is move the needle from
49 to 50 to 51 it's not like you need to
go from 40
to 60 percent so 100 million dollars
might buy you
5 000 votes 10 000 votes 25 000 votes
the needle doesn't have to be moved that
far that's like saying hey he's going to
spend 100 million dollars in california
to
flip it red okay cool good luck with
that you know
on the other side of course of course
but on on con there's a reason he's
doing it in florida
because it's very a movable state it's a
very purple
state that can be swayed one way or
another
you